our week at Comic Con is being made
possible thanks to our friends at
Snickers that's that's right when you
think about it
Snickers sponsoring our show during
comic-con makes perfect sense doesn't it
Andy
it sure does Conan at Comic Con fans
line up to attend the most popular
panels and to get autographs from TV and
movie stars and lines can feel even
longer on an empty stomach
Snickers takes care of that these super
fans have been waiting in line can you
tell which one had a Snickers bar
[Applause]
no wonder Snickers the official candy
bar of waiting in lines to attend
popular panels or get autographs from TV
and movie stars you're a winner buddy
thank you we're looking for that that's
gonna be a that's gonna be a really fun
week shows and
we we forgot to work that part out of
rehearsal claw claw claw we can just
edit that part out no I love that part I
want to see that again where I'm talking
in Andy walks right in front of me I
want to see that part again and I'm just
having a regular show
[Applause]
I love it